[Musique]
bonjour pierre monteux bonjour monsieur
viol dont vous êtes le directeur de
banat mart banham art c'est le
groupement des planteurs de la banane et
de la martinique la banane qui fait
sérieusement grise mine après le passage
de l'ouragan maria on y arrive dans
quelques secondes mais concernant les
dégâts de 2,7 de cet ouragan on a
entendu ce matin que les parlementaires
de martinique ont demandé à la ministre
d outre-mer la déclaration d'état de
calamité agricole ça changerait quoi
pour vous alors c'est une nécessité
effectivement d'avoir cette
reconnaissance de la calamité agricole
puisque c'est cette décision qui sera
prise par le ministère de l'outre-mer
qui permettra donc aux préfets justement
de signer son décret de calamité
agricole et d'engager donc le processus
de déclaration des pertes que qu'on
subit donc les producteurs de bananes
aussi bien au niveau du fond c'est à
dire des bananeraies qu'au niveau des
récoltes c'est à dire la production qui
a été perdue du fait de mariam et puis
tout de suite ce moratoire sur les
dettes sociales et fiscales des
sinistrés russie s'est aussi donc une
nécessité
on sort donc d'une année qui a été déjà
difficile puisque nous l'oublions pas
donc il ya moins d'un an
or on a déjà subit donc les affres donc
de matthew avec des pertes qui était
conséquente
les producteurs se remettait tout
doucement de cet événement climatique de
2016 et à moins d'un an après donc on a
de nouveau donc
c'est un nouvel un nouveau cyclone qui
vient donc endommager considérablement
les planteurs et leur trésorerie et
leurs finances une semaine après le
passage de deux mariés à quel bilan
faites vous exactement de ces dégâts
dans les plantations indiqué alors on
n'en ont peut on peut estimer donc à peu
près donc les pertes de deux régions
quand même bien distinctes on a dans
toute la partie nord c'est-à-dire
au-dessus de trinité qui est détruite à
100 %
là il n'ya pas y'a pas photo
donc on a des mêmes là vous faites une
distinction en liga le plan qui peut
être couché mais pas complètement
déracinés alors paradoxalement cette
année à la différence de mathieu on a
donc un taux de plants arrachés
c'est à dire donc où la plante a été
arrachée à ses importants alors que haut
niveau donc de mathieu on avait eu
plutôt des plans qui avait été coupé
enfin cassé et là effectivement donc les
techniques de redémarrage vont être
totalement différente entre donc ces
deux cas de figure et ces deux
situations mais revenons un peu au
pertre est donc assez forcé la décision
au niveau de trinité donc de trinité
donc jusqu'à grand rivière est quasiment
jusqu'à donc saint pierre c'est
effectivement donc une bananeraie qui
est aujourd'hui à terre malheureusement
c'est quand même donc la zone de
production donc la plus importante de
notre île ça représente à peu près 60 60
les deux tiers donc de la production
martiniquaise et dans cette région donc
du nord atlantique et du nord caraïbes
au niveau du centre c'est assez mitigé
on a un taux de perte qui est aux
alentours de 25 30% sur le lamantin sur
sur saint joseph sur ducos sur ducos et
au sud un peu plus de pertes autour de
40% donc de pertes sur les parties donc
dû françois et du vauclin alors ça
représente combien en cash en liquide en
euros très très schématiquement d'ici la
fin de l'année
on avait une vision de production aux
alentours de 150 mille tonnes
on va atterrir à peu près donc à 110 115
mille tonnes c'est à dire au revoir
entre 35 et 40 mille tonnes de perdus
chaque tonne ça représente quand même
600 euros donc vous imaginez bien donc
le montant c'est plus de 20 millions
d'euros en pertes de récoltes en perte
fac de de chiffre d'affaires et de
production après au niveau donc des
pertes de fonds c'est à dire
l'investissement qu'il faudra refaire
pour relancer donc la production
là c'est un petit peu tôt mais pour vous
donnez donc une grandeur d'idées haut
niveau donc de matthew nous avions perdu
entre les pertes de fonds et les pertes
de récolte estimée par l'administration
à peu près 45 millions d'euros 45
millions d'euros sur l'année 2016 45
millions d'euros
malheureusement donc on terme
d'indemnisation on avait reçu à peine on
a reçu 7,5 millions 7 et on attend
encore 4 millions d'euros on voit bien
qu fait la grimace à ce que la banane
on a quand même tendance à a constaté
que la banane n'arrête pas de faire
grise mine la bella n'arrêtent pas de se
plaindre n'aurait pas assuré pour face à
ce genre de malheureusement donc non
parce qu'effectivement les clauses
d'assurance ou les contrats d'assurance
par rapport à ce risque sont assez rares
peu de peu d'assurance peuvent le mettre
en place un donc on expertise ça alors
je rappelle quand même que dans la loi
sur l'égalité réelle donc à une
disposition qui a été no prises un
amendement qui a été pris pour mettre en
place au niveau de l'outre-mer pas fonds
de secours qui soit un petit peu donc
différent du fonds de secours que l'on à
aujourd'hui qui est un fonds de secours
mis en place par l'eau des par le
ministère donc d outre-mer et kinés
abondé que par bercy donc forcément donc
on est donc limité donc par les moyens
de bercy pas mange avec la banane avait
des lobbyings très très très fort et
très efficace c'est difficile on connaît
donc on connaît malheureusement donc les
finances de l'état il est clair il est
clair que pour maria il faudra que
l'état fasse un effort conséquent parce
que effectivement donc les pertes sont
extrêmement donc importante
les chiffres et donc pour l'instant ces
cétacés donc c'est assez chiffré
monétairement c'est encore un peu
pompeux un peu tôt mais on n'est pas les
seuls d'ailleurs donc il ya la
guadeloupe possible ré bananeraies
guadeloupéen a été détruite à 100 % donc
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans une position où au niveau
de la martinique
on est détruit donc à 60 70 % la
guadeloupe à 100%
il va falloir relancer donc la machine
relance et donc la mécanique pour vous
dire et entre les producteurs de bananes
des antilles ils achètent des terrains
peu partout des des plantations un peu
partout dans le monde en afrique non en
fin d'année si les anglophones non pas
dans les agresseurs anglophone
effectivement dont il ya eu des projets
qui ont été portées donc au niveau de
l'afrique un partez produite en
guadeloupe et un ou des producteurs
martiniquais qui nous le rend bien utile
aujourd'hui qui nous seront bien utiles
parce que je rappelle effectivement
qu'on est donc un réseau de muret s'il
en faut 20 séries dont on va produire
là-bas y faire ça passait sous le compte
de la production antillaise a pas du
tout heureusement qu'il ya une
traçabilité qui existe qui existe et que
les origines donc reste fiable
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'effectivement on a je rappelle en
raison de mûrisserie qui est le réseau
fruit d'or qui a vocation à
commercialiser donc ses bananes
antillaises et qu il le fait d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui donc elle se retrouve donc
avec des volumes qui sont en attrition
enfin qui sont quasiment inexistants et
pourtant il faut qu'elle tourne il faut
que les clients soient satisfaits et
bien évidemment donc il a fait retrouver
donc d'autres origines et ses origines
africaines
alors qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
pour les 400 planteurs que nous avons
recensé ici en martinique sur cinq mille
900 ha ça représente combien de salariés
d'après 3500 salariés directs alors ils
sont en chômage technique
alors certains vont être donc mis en
activité partielle sur le dispositif de
l'activité partielle on a des contacts
aujourd'hui avec la dieccte pour pour
enclencher donc ce dispositif le plus
rapidement possible possible notamment
par rapport à donc à tout le personnel
qui était affecté donc à l'emballage
haut niveau donc deschamps il ya comme
un travail important qui est à faire
donc de nettoyage des parcelles de 6
clonage de replantation qui va se faire
progressivement
mais effectivement donc il y aura une
partie importante des salariés
malheureusement qui seront mis en
activité partielle
le projet reçoit aussi un exemple on
cherche aussi donc léger rendez vous
donc jeudi prochain avec le directeur
régional du fafsea pour mettre en place
aussi un plan ambitieux donc de
formation il s'avère croix il faut enfin
il ya beaucoup de formations aux
formations techniques
parce qu'effectivement donc et à la
nécessité donc de les former technique
vous savez donc on a un enjeu qui est
relativement important qui est la lutte
contre la circo sports news noir qui
nécessite effectivement une formation
donc importantes et les techniques
changent
il ya des progrès qui sont faits dans
qu'en la matière et il faut diffuser
donc ces nouvelles techniques de lutte
contre la circo sports news doit par
exemple les évoquer cette cette
recherche
on va aller vers une banane plus propre
avec moins de pesticides en vue d'une
banane débarrasser de cette
cercosporiose peut-on envisager une
banane plus résistantes au vent dieu de
nous à caen c'est là le paradoxe parce
que effectivement quand on fait de la
recherche au niveau d'une variété qui
est résistante à la cercosporiose noire
malheureusement donc on a des bananiers
qui sont plus haut donc ils sont plus
sujets donc au vent donc retrouver donc
la comtesse la compatibilité dont elle
accuse revanche toujours la peinture se
venge toujours donc là c'est compliqué
effectivement oui on est une banane plus
durable aujourd'hui
oui on a considérablement baissé donc
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires et on terme d'herbicides
par exemple on a baissé donc de plus de
30% donc les consommations ou
des 12 derniers mois tout simplement
parce que donc aujourd'hui dans les
bananeraies qu on tolère donc de l'herbe
on a des plantes de service on a des
plantes de couverture et on a engagé
dans nos producteurs sur une gestion
mécanique de l'enherbement c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on désherbe plus donc
avec des produits phyto mais on passe
des débroussailleuses en passe d
gyrobroyeur qui permettent effectivement
sur les surcoûts pour vous ce sont des
surcoûts mais mais la vie reprend dans
les bananeraies
mais la vie reprend ce sont des sciences
avait recensé combien d'espèces cinq ans
et nouri apparation dans les bananes
énormément et on le voit aujourd'hui par
exemple
gt gt sur une exploitation jeudi qui
fait justement donc de la gestion donc
en herbe et donc de ses parcelles
on a eu beaucoup moins donc de coulées
de boue c'est à dire qu'au niveau des
traces donc est venu faire son mea culpa
vous parle toujours de bananes mea culpa
mea culpa c'est un inventaire parce que
effectivement donc on vit dans un
environnement donc et cet environnement
donc permet donc des choses ou ne permet
pas donc des choses donc forcément donc
on s'est adapté aussi par rapport à cet
environnement
je pense qu'on est même en avance par
rapport à cet environnement je rappelle
que on est quand même dans la filière
qui a respecté donc les objectifs du
grenelle de l'environnement en cinq ans
alors que donc ses objectifs étaient
fixés donc sur dix ans et qu' aucune
autre filière agricole française ne les
a respectés sauf la banane dont je crois
qu'il faut donc le reconnaître il faut
en être fier c'est chez nous c'est en
martinique
aujourd'hui effectivement donc on a un
challenge de relever donc d'autres
plantations après marjah on va le faire
ça sera difficile il faut qu'on est donc
le soutien de l'état d'où effectivement
c'est nécessité donc de l'arrêté de
calamité agricole et d'intervention du
fonds de secours à deux mots oui ou non
la banane martiniquais s'est aujourd'hui
comme unique évolue très vite de faire
j'espère qu'elle le sait en tout cas il
faut on essaye de progresser en la
matière merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
magazine dont je rappelle que vous êtes
le directeur de banamart ce groupement
de bananes des de la martinique que vous
faites partie de l'union générale de la
banane antillaise du gpmh merci merci
merci beaucoup bonne journée
[Musique]